hello hey hey babe
did I wake you I've just set the hotel
or thought to have some breakfast
listen take it why you're doing this
it's just a lion that kills me
I need you to know that you can tell me
anything David David
yeah I gotta call you like that is
everything okay
what
my name is David Pak else I'm 22 years
old and I'm an international arms dealer
six months ago I was in massage
therapist to Miami Beach sorry in film
and now here I was with my best friend
for the junior high I know you should
come work for me I'm against this war
this isn't about being pro war this is
about being pro money other three
twenty-something young men lands a 300
million dollar Pentagon contracts you
told me you guys were selling bedsheets
I also told you that we're selling other
stuff too I thought you meant pillows
100 million rounds for ak-47 ammo you
can feel the whole order
I'm barred from doing any business with
the US government I'm gonna watch this
you're on a terrorist watch this do work
for Homeland Security relax bro this is
the job to do business with the people
the US government can't do business with
directly
we're on the verge making 300 million
dollars is that legal
it's not illegal
I like that certain situation I have to
ask myself what would a bad man do
is this safe drive in the back then that
is safe
fifty-fifty but like fish have you lived
favors and we die yes
this is why we drive through the night
it is much safer how much safer 50/50 Oh